yes I welcome it very much contrary to
what John Bolton has just said I think
that it makes it much less likely that
Iran could ever create a nuclear bomb
then if there was no deal and what
people like mr. Bolton and indeed Prime
Minister Netanyahu in Israel failed to
take into account is what would have
happened if there was no deal because if
there was no deal in my judgment the
international consensus in favor of
tough sanctions would have started to
fall apart it's been remarkable that
China and Russia and the European Union
and the United States has stayed
together for so long
to negotiate this deal but China and
Russia been very anxious to build up
trade and political relations with Iran
and within the European Union very
strong commercial pressures indeed
particularly in Germany and Italy for
breaking down sanctions you would have
seen those decay without any of the very
intrusive inspection arrangements which
are fundamental a fundamental part of
this agreement those who are skeptical
would say that just the fact that a deal
has been done is no guarantee they will
say look at Bill Clinton in 1994 who
hailed a momentous agreement in which a
guarantee that North Korea wouldn't be
able to build nuclear weapons and we
know that since then they say they're
carried out successful tests so why
should we trust this deal well one thing
Iran is not North Korea and that's the
fun most fundamental reason you've got
to make a judgment based on the way this
country is it North Korea is right in
one extreme it's a completely
totalitarian state and it's frankly
sheltered as well for complex reasons by
China Iran's in a very different
circumstance and as we've heard from
professor judges just now the sanctions
have really bitten our on Iran they've
got a young population it is a large
population it's the size of Turkey and
there are huge pressures internally in
favour of Iran becoming part of the
international community and shifting its
international focus now the great
frustration is we almost came close to a
deal had it not be in for intransigence
I'm afraid by John Bolton and other
people in the
US administration in 2005 six we could
have had a deal we could have had a deal
when it was Hassan rouhani was across
the table from us negotiating at that
stage Iran's nuclear power program was
in relative infancy there 200
centrifuges there now Goddard getting on
for twenty thousand so a lot of years
have been lost but I'm in no doubt that
having read this document and it runs
250 pages
it's an extraordinary detailed document
it pins Iran down and some of its
provisions were last for 25 years well
you say that and yet as you will know
Iran's critics its enemies are fearful
that Iran is hell-bent on acquiring
nuclear weapons and all they've agreed
to now is a delay and that is all and of
one concessions in the meantime I don't
think there's any significant evidence
that Iran is today intent on acquiring
nuclear weapons there was which is why
the negotiations started back in 2003
the last National Intelligence Estimate
which was published by the United States
was that they judged that Iran stopped
seriously trying to develop a nuclear
weapons program in 2003 now I've always
worked on the basis that what Iran has
been trying to do particularly under
Ahmadinejad was to get together the
technology so they could move to
weaponize as systems with nuclear
warheads if they so chose what this deal
does is set that back very significantly
and I think Iranian leaders today under
rouhani and under the supreme leader
judge that it's not in their interests
to have a nuclear weapons program and it
makes them much more vulnerable and the
moment there is any suspicion at all
that they can do that sanctions go back
and they become a pariah and i don't
think they'll be willing to risk that is
there a risk though of an arms race in
the region if Saudi Arabia for example
was mistrustful of the deal might it
feel compelled to develop a nuclear
program and deepen those silly sheer
divides all of that region there are
serious anxieties in the Arab world
amongst the Saudis and amongst the Gulf
states which we all need to take account
of they're worried about Iran developing
a hegemony in the area I think it's for
Western leaders particularly
particularly President Obama and Prime
Minister Cameron and others to try to
swage those fears I think one has to
understand them historically as well so
I don't dismiss those fears but I also
hope that what the leaders will say to
the Gulf states and to Saudi Arabia is
that this is a much better situation
than what would have happened if there
had been no deal at all because being no
doubt no deal would not have represented
a continuation of the status quo it
would have ended up with a terrible mess
and as for an arms race
I doubt it actually very much because in
the end in practice
Saudi Arabia can shelter behind the
nuclear shield of the United States and
the Iranians are not they're not stupid
they're not going to start engaging in a
conflict either with the Saudis all with
the Gulf states which could lead to
anywhere anything approaching a nuclear
conflict because they would lose